what is up everybody it's an iMac here
for anime uproar and guys we got some
big news right now we just got some
really big news about attack on Titan
season 3 a huge update thanks to anime
world from our discord for letting me
know about it right away so I decided to
what I'll do is I'll go live right here
on the channel I will wait to make a
video and edit it I'll go live to let
you guys know what's going on right away
so ok we are live basically guys what's
happening is we just got the news Anime
News Network reported it and also
crunchyroll just reported that attack on
Titan season 3 will be premiering in
July July of 2018 and there will be a
brand new compilation film of season 2
in January of 2018 so a new film is
coming out January 2018 only a few
months from now however season 3 we have
to wait till July apparently for season
3 to comes out we thought that season 3
would be coming out in April in spring
2018 we were led to believe that however
it looks like July 2018 we're gonna have
to wait till July that's at least what
official news sources are reporting
anime news network and crunchyroll
so yeah interesting stuff guys we also
got a brand new promotional image of
season 3 that you can see here if you
read the manga you will recognize this
scene very important seeing we see Levi
there at the bottom we see Aaron tied up
at the top and another brand new
character is shown only his legs and
guns here in the foreground I don't want
to spoil too much but yeah very
important character for the next arc
really interesting really cool image for
those also read the manga iconic image
we know what happens in this scene but I
don't want to ruin it too much I won't
talk about it too much guys
but yes exciting news on the one hand we
are getting season 3 however I would
have prefered it earlier also no news
yet on how many episodes were gonna be
getting so that is another thing that is
a bit of an issue
however hopefully we're gonna get them
announcement soon that there's gonna be
twenty five episodes twenty four
episodes we know that this arc is the
next arc upcoming so I hope that I hope
that you know we're gonna get this arc
and go to the next arc as well and get a
full 24 25 episode season I'm hoping
that the fact that we got the
announcement that it's gonna be
postponed to July means that we're at
least going to get a full 25 episode
season however obviously no confirmation
I'm a bit worried because I don't like
the fact that it was that it was
postponed in this way because we all
know how long season 2 was postponed so
it is a bit worrying to me personally
that it got postponed but I'm really
hoping that we are gonna get it at least
in July that it's gonna be a full season
of course here on the channel we're
gonna keep you posted as soon as we get
news about any other further updates so
yeah stay tuned that's why I wanted to
go live right now and get you this
information as soon as I possibly could
and yes so we have here information on
my anime news network that attack on
Titan full movie and by the way all this
information came from a special event a
special event on attack on Titan event
in a nuttin that was just I think
yesterday or today this was confirmed it
was a special attack intense season 2
event and it was confirmed okay movie in
January is coming and now we also have a
season 3 announcement for July yeah
interesting news exciting it was a bit
worrying as I said cuz I really want to
see this season coming soon but yeah
guys at the chat let me know how you're
feeling about this I see lightning
darkness
Todoroki and a bunch of people in the
chat how are you feeling about this are
you excited are you worried let me know
let me know by the way if you want to
see just this image by itself it's
pretty freaking epic I love I love
seeing this iconic manga seen in such a
kind of crisp anime style image it's
just
just good stuff good stuff so yeah kind
of good news kind of bad news in terms
of having to wait longer however we're
gonna stay on top of it and keep you
posted right here on the channel as soon
as we get more news we're gonna keep you
posted hopefully we're gonna get that
full season and yeah let me know in the
comments how you're feeling about this
are you excited are you excited are you
worried because if they keep postponing
this I'm gonna be so pissed guys we know
how long we have to wait for season two
for years I definitely do not want to
wait for four years or anything close to
that for season three so they better not
postpone it longer than summer or next
year I'm serious guys I know I have no
power or saying this but ah yeah I see a
lot of people in the chat are excited so
that's good to see
oh hi guys hype very cool by the way
some of you guys might know about that
anime snob the famous and infamous anime
commentator just want to quickly inform
you that he will be uh that he contacted
me and he if you have followed if you
followed rent cafe you will know that
one second I'm hearing some background
noise okay yeah sorry about that it was
an ad on the website I don't know if you
guys heard it but just making sure yeah
so basically that anime snob he wrote a
book a while back and we roasted it we
critiqued it on ran cafe which you guys
know ranked efface a podcast that we do
on this channel
he said he contacted me and said that
apparently he edited the book to reflect
some of my criticisms including adding a
character more of a character that I
really liked in the book so I will leave
the link to his book in the description
if you want to check that out I'm
excited to see what changes he made
based on my critique so that'll be
interesting to see anyway let me see now
in the chat a bit how people are feeling
about this whole news thing about this
whole big update yeah and yeah I
apologize that this is also last you
know kind of last minute just like going
live but I didn't know what a better way
to do bring this to you as soon as
possible
um fun times guys fun times for sure
yeah got people but we'll soul madness
what's up my man yeah he a soul madness
he thought great content created by the
way he thought that it was coming out in
spring me too
that's what they told us initially you
guys will remember when photography in
season 2 ended
they said season 3 spring 2018 so yeah
this is kind of a delayed which is an
issue but again still very excited I
want to see it as long as we don't get
more delays I don't want to see more
delays and so people are talking did
they really hope it's gonna be a 25 so
season that's gonna cover the next two
arcs the uprising arc return to shegaon
China arc yes I definitely want to see
both of those I feel like they really go
well together if it's a 12 season will
probably have to only cover the uprising
art or really skip over it which you
know could cause issues because a lot of
important stuff happens in these arcs
really important world-building
important things are learned about the
titans about the walls so much stuff
guys so much stuff about the inner
workings of the monarchy and the system
within the walls so I definitely want to
see a full 25 episode season if my hero
academia could do it after season 1 12
episodes they right away next year the
following year had a 25 episode full
season which are obviously aired this
year so if they can do it attack my tank
and do it a tagging time is hugely
popular amazingly popular so let's hope
for the best
let's hope for the best guys yeah
imperialist opinions is hoping for a
good pacing definitely I want to see
good Pacey I don't want to see them rush
it I don't wanna see them draw it out
there's plenty of material in the manga
the manga chapters by the way come out
monthly and we have been reviewing them
right here on the channel you can check
those out if you're caught up to the
manga really interesting stuff it's just
really uh cooking up to become an
amazing showdown soon in those new
chapters so I'm really looking forward
to that plenty of manga material for a
full season 3 for those of you
that's not an issue so I really hope
that we're gonna see a full season three
full season for you guys be sure to let
me know what you think about all of this
in the comments
once this stream has uploaded as well I
don't want to take too much of your time
basically to sum up again we have season
3 confirmed for July 2018 instead of
fault of spring 2018 so looks like a bit
of a delay however new compilation film
for season 2 coming out in January which
we knew nothing about before this point
and of course we also do know that OVA s
will be coming The Lost Girls obas which
center around Annie and Mikasa the first
one of those is coming in December so in
only two months less than two months and
then two more are coming next year
they'll be packaged with the new volumes
of the manga so a lot of stuff is
happening regarding attack on Titan just
yeah this whole delay thing is a bit of
an issue but this image this promotional
image for someone who's read the manga
definitely gets me hyped up and excited
so yeah that's what we have so far if we
get some other big news on this front I
will update you as soon as I can of
course and yeah exciting stuff let me
know what you think down in the comments
stay tuned to the channel until next
time see our space cowboys